- Well, I mentioned euphoria.
- Yes.
- Which you starred with Zendaya,
and I, I didn't know this,
but the first time you met
her, we found this picture.
Look at her in this photo.
- [Actress] I was a baby.
- [Kelly] She is a baby.
- [Actress] Oh my God, baby.
- [Actress 2] Baby, baby.
- [Kelly] I had a-
I, I mean, what kinda life do you have
to where you meet her as a young-
and then now you work with her.
It's just...
- It's wild.
It's a blessing.
- [Kelly] That's crazy.
- Yeah, that was at the
Ben and Jerry's in Burbank.
I was on the way.
- [Kelly] First of all, nice choice.
- Yeah!
- Half Baked is my favorite.
- [Actress] Exactly.
- [Kelly] Okay. Nice.
- I, I was there.
I was about to go to the AMC,
and I heard a familiar voice, and you know
when you hear from familiar
voice, you turn around.
I was ordering my ice cream
and then I just look over my shoulder
and she's right there.
And I literally stood there
for probably about two minutes
and I was just like...
and my mom was like,
"You're being embarrassing.
You're either gonna go say hi,
or don't say anything at all."
And now we're like, she's my big sis.
We get to work together.
And I just admire and love her.
- I just love that.
That is, you know, sometimes we can like,
harp on this city for a lot
of things that aren't great
but it's a beautiful
dreamer's place, you know?
It is.
- Absolutely.
- It's like, it's really
cool that you dream
like that when you're a kid.
You have this goal, you meet
this person that inspires you,
and you end up working.
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] That's a really cool story.
- It's very cool.